now you know what comes after the great
food of thanksgiving it's the great
shopping of black friday esther sarpong
is here to talk black friday at fashion
show las vegas esther
are you ready
i feel like this is a game day for you
guys right it is game day for us for
black friday but i think it's game day
for so many family members in the valley
especially because last year people
weren't able to gift together
and so this year everyone is looking for
that special gift that says i love you
absolutely and also gives you great
savings and that's what fashion show las
vegas offers
we are expecting incredible savings i
left the shopping center to come see you
when it was busy it was already busy
it's already busy oh my gosh oh my gosh
so what can people expect at fashion
show for black friday for black friday
fashion show las vegas has over 250
stores 30 dining locations over 2
million square feet of shopping dining
and entertainment because black friday
kicks off our holiday show holiday glow
live about that minute we'll talk about
that in a minute it is so much fun but
let's talk about shopping incredible
savings incredible opportunities to
really find that perfect gift and get
great coupons and be able to get in line
and score that present that makes
everyone smile right now i know you've
been doing this a long time so what are
those stores that people really tend to
go for for black friday oh we have less
deals give me some examples do you want
to know the secret girl
i have to tell you that a lot of the
stores have great deals let's start with
our anchor tenants we have neiman
markets we have newman markets we have
nordstrom's we have forever 21. they
already started their deals already we
have new to market retailers or ones
that offer customization like lip lab by
bite love them oh you can make a custom
lipstick shade so if you're a girl like
me who loves great lipstick you can shop
there and find those amazing deals and
the red we're wearing today yes we are
rocking the ride together and it's a
perfect place to shop and throughout the
whole shopping center they're just
really great finds whether you're
shopping for your boyfriend your
girlfriend you know a girl's night out a
guy's night or a baby shower we've got
you covered i love it and it's just so
much fun to be in there too you know
it's just a good energy speaking of as
you're walking through shopping you have
holiday activation so some entertainment
tell us about those really quick
entertainment fashion show is key for
holiday we know that people want to take
a break sometimes and just check in and
make sure that you shop for everyone
holiday glow it's our live show it's
back with us it happens
at the top of the hour at 11 1 2 i mean
11 1 3 and 5. and we're seeing it right
now you're seeing it right now it has
contemporary dance it has hip-hop it's
got ballerinas it's got a little bit of
everything to bring a little bit of
cheer 15 minutes at the top of the hour
and check out the show times on our
website fslv.com and that's where you
can also get a reservation for the other
holiday activations as well right
absolutely santa's back in town we have
pet nights with santa and for families
that need a little bit of quiet time we
also have a partnership with autism
speech
where you're able to get that quiet time
with santa as well beautiful thank you
so much esther so much going on at
fashion show you gotta check it out okay
so